ciao a tutti andrà a finire
ciao a tutti bene non bisogna neanche
force
oggi andiamo a fare un mica box di testo
è sbagliata e tristi che a capire che
era la possibilità mi sembrava la mia
voce
iniziamo bene questo video allora come
potete vedere dal tavolo oggi super
mailer gigante o le di cose per
distrarmi
abbiamo un tag dipeso da farvi vedere
non solo anche qualche a questo tiger
primark in più questo kit riordinato da
amazon e ho visto c'è anche suo modo
l'italia che in pratica include un sacco
di tipo 60 decorazioni 60 pacchetti di
decorazioni per l'utente di rigore di
aprirlo vederlo con voi vedrete le vale
la pena comunque questo è un altro dei
video con shopping virtuale e parti ha
detto verrete con noi a fare tutto
questo shopping assieme a noi così
evidente anche tutto il resto
so che c'è nel negozio se volete che
prendevo qualcos'altro potete scrivere
nei commenti la prossima volta che
torniamo lavoro andiamo siete pronti 3 2
1 abbiamo fatto falsato 08
poi come suggellato forma di rosa in più
lo abbiamo preso senza la e quindi began
e allora il mio è banana e cioccolato il
tuo e basilico il limone è frutto della
passione
beh allora ancora assaggiato perché
buonissimo
l'unico è strano
ora sembra che abbiamo pezzi dibattiti
potente dove assaggiare
noi
in particolare tante quando shop la
prima cosa interessante questa maschera
prof argentata anche dorata troviamo
anche questa tante realtà quante ne
prende di questi
tutti quanti non prendiamoci cura
ma fatica che questi non sono giappone
tipo carino
poi dobbiamo prendere della lozione in
realtà anche del sapone schiumoso
vediamo se lo troviamo vediamo cocco si
sono un po corato così di cocco su un
unicorno qualche bello ma anche feste
contenitori personali ma questi farà un
po g però adesso altri
[Musica]
poi ci sono dei fiocchi e guardate un po
c'è anche un host line e non so se vi
ricordate questo l'avevo già comprato
una volta ma non è bello per niente poi
abbiamo questi tre tipi di slime notte
che strano dinosauro brillantinato
questo verte ormai ci sono slime ovunque
vero che cesserà di tempo si terrà roba
dentro sì ma è normale questa cosa ma la
potete spiegare per favore non capisco
forse un gioco per cani
si ok ma anche se un gioco per cani e
inquietantissimo
un gioco per te
[Musica]
abbiamo un po di colori però non mi
piacciono tantissimo così colore super
neon quindi non penso che li prendo
questi anche belle queste cose fare
rientro a scuola sono molto carine sei
classi lupi online bello
abbiamo un palloncino questo mi ci
butterei dentro ma non penso che sia
grandi abbastanza per me troppo piscine
o per picchiare un po ai box perché boy
l'unicorno che non manca mai
oddio perché sono unicorno decapitato
una tua penna
ci sono dei clipper bene al mare non sa
che prendo questi arancio e i gialli
questa invece colorante con un po di
brillantini dentro sorridiamoci altro
che pura passione apriamo un po chissà
come sono questi nello slam
che dite proviamo sestito pv harding
sarà davvero pilia ma perché a questo
colore giallognolo già detto problemi
cosa non mi convince molto
questo ed inter lo stesso con la colla
dentro altri glitter e se questo questa
è una sorta di plastilina da modellare
una sorta di slide penso di posizione
sono altre
siamo da dei cinesi e c'è veramente di
tutto la prima volta che veniamo qua ma
enorme aiuto complete
[Applauso]
se questi possono interessanti per lo
slime colore ragazzi che faccio prendo
una parrucca e colore
sono piatte di colori molto naturali o
così possono provare un michael mcdonald
[Musica]
[Risate]
comunque al contrario vediamo spa
sia la carota che ci sono bellissimi
[Applauso]
questo non si danna per trasparente
tutte quante le frazioni
se c'è qualcosa di interessante
cammina proprio colore non capisco bene
questi palazzi che fuori
che cazzo
[Musica]
bellissimi i pupazzi giganti per sempre
berto si batte per gli hanno messo un
auspicio brutto
tutto questo outfit per un enorme è
questa solo 15 euro
vediamo chi è in tuffo un minion ma
cos'è questo imprenditore minion questa
sera o al più brutto sembro io con mi
sveglierò mattina
andiamo in questo negozio giganteschi
qui c'è veramente di tutto
ho fatto questi qua per fare il pit bull
la chiamo cristiano dei diamanti lì
che colore prendo certo se fosse uno
squizzi questo c'è guerra combattuta
però stai a premere e non si preme
quindi è solo una lattuga finta ma
perché sono qua qua
segui la mia voce guardate quante
analisi sono il figlio carnevale lontano
malfa lumine vicino questa che questo
appello forte e cappello da indiano poi
ci sono delle ali rosse
[Musica]
se le cose via halloween fisico poi da
cosa vi vestirete questo halloween e 24
pin virtuale che sia piaciuto e ora
finalmente in molla di tutte le cose che
abbiamo preso allora graham iniziale
delle cose piccoline che lui abbia
questi due kit capospalla prendono molto
frammentata vi ricordate che allora in
tutta la sua parte vediamo questo sono
state artistica be nice
ne abbiamo dei pali del razzo con cost
che sono sono un po misti abbiamo questo
novaris colore
[Musica]
non so come uscirà una busta di elastici
che ho preso io perché non si sa mai
quando quando possono servire anche come
lo so me lo ricordo che avevo detto ha
fatto 10 donne serviva per peraltro per
montare il microfono sulla la masters
cup e le ragazze meetic si avvicina
morante per slam per farli morbidi
profumati e anche i suoni e anche i suoi
fanno le folle di colorno sopra facendo
certo sappiamo lo ricordo ma sul post
non mln comodo questo permette di essere
uno capitolo fora come metterli dove
abbiamo questi due glitter arsene giallo
shower cream coni
questo probabilmente come quell'altro
anche per gli slider profumati dovevamo
di costo poco che la donna come lozioni
questi ma dove c'è un giallo ma poi
abbiamo delle pil of silver mask
complesse ed ovviamente lo ska peskov
alla folla però queste mi interessavano
particolarmente perché queste argentata
e questa è guardate guardate d'ora altra
realtà era finito in quella di vedere
come gli slam argentato è migliorato
perché mi sapere nei commenti
ed è subito quelle finalmente abbiamo i
nuovi comandi allora sono emerse inizio
ci sarà tanto lo sapete si dicono ranzi
sono in condizioni pietose
ogni volta che li prende un rimarchiamo
tutte le mani ma siamo dappertutto
vitale sera abbiamo un tacco perché
sporcava premetto che quindi erano
quindi la wilton che purtroppo non si
possono spremere bisogna preparare
qualcosa dentro e prenderli quindi ho
preso questi mostri sono poi vi lascio
comunque tp link in descrizione per mi
riguarda per i dimentico arancione
finalmente un giallo prepara la canzone
brynas cloud drive la più brillante
poi abbiamo gergo ma è il tedesco io
credo che sia sincera esigendo il 12
giallo per questo che presa dal suo
crescente destra che regola il
management e del flauto e blu comunque
giallo rosso blu blu in se qualcun altra
squadra
si sentirà molto spesso si pungerà
sessuali giusto come questa mela che del
lago persone a chi oggi quelli che una
rete di sapere nei commenti
di che colore ma ce la faremo a colori
da tiger preso queste scarpine in
pratica appena volessero delle scarpe
col tacco fintamente e fermano per
tenere il telefono io queste postazioni
computer è di tale miglio mi metto il
telefono a fianco è molto rigido a
guardare il mondo quindi con questi
possono che attaccate eccole qua che
carini si oppose il telefono sopra e si
possono guardare i video qui sotto
tallinn e c'erano anche i nervi ma
sapete che io loro volta bellissima poi
prossima cosa intenda barba che sapete
che diverse con la schiuma da barba
perché si espande dopo e
bollicine che sono smr rispetto alla
schiuma da barba però cosa in più
spiegano perché c'è da parte di qualcuno
parla per cento via più che un morbido
si spalma meglio intorno ai peli sulla
barba quindi prima marchi national no
più facile da allora prossima volta che
preso da primer che questi erano
scontati da 6 euro a 3 euro all'ora sono
i cosiddetti per fare i ghiaccioli anche
se è solo disney sapete che io sono una
grandissima fan fin qui quindi non
potevo non prenderli e che alle orecchie
di topolino soprattutto con temi
d'estate sono i colori perché i colori
quando mi fanno impazzire
avrebbe scritto di colori pastello
presso carini sicuramente tutti saprete
come funziona la pasta aprirli mettere
dentro coca cola che diventi un
ghiacciolo puoi chiudere di smetterl in
freezer e poi americano ha poi ho preso
una di 2.346 moltissimo da barba non c'è
bisogno che vi spiega sapete benissimo
al proprio interno notte la cassiera ci
guardava
per il video faccio 17 brutte figure
l'altra volta abbiamo allora sapete che
abbiamo fatto il video dei guanti e
questo gli ingredienti design e tre
guardie e poi abbiamo fatto il video sta
scatta umanità che quell'uomo lo slam
manetta quindi le cose ci ha visto
comprare i guanti memorial audits le
manette e c'è un'altra cosa che due
nostri bright c'erano altre cose che
pare neanche la briga di ogni volta
allora qui ho preso queste decorazioni
che sono per fare il bis volo in
generale di fare uno stage che
scricchiola un po tipo franchi saranno
bari con i giornalisti si sono visti poi
questo permette i korn dentro perché io
a te come ambito quindi non è il nostro
spera ticino un budget pieno di contorno
cui questo non si trova titolare non
preso da primark ed è una bottiglia
dell'acqua però in vetro finalmente
perché le fanno sempre in plastica ma
sapete il vetro è molto più salutare
eccola qua oli che si sta quel colore
tra mai poi prossima cosa che ho preso
solo questo elastici a molla e ha
precisato di più perché sono gli unici
che non mi danno fossili e fatele che
non mi lascia il segno più belli dove
entrò in continuazione e quindi ne ho
preso altre questa volta ho tanto su
viola lille volta qui mi trovo io però
nel mio zaino o nella borsa dalla
macchina fotografica ma viene quest'anno
sarà così
certo è per il bagno dividere questo per
il bagno preso questo sforzo di grillano
è bellissimo
e poi questo per il sapone per le mani
per non stare sempre in tripla stica
anche perché noi utilizziamo
le buste per inquinare la mia moglie di
plastica poi quest'anno si torna niente
perché sono vecchi allora iniziamo con
questo perché non vedevo l'ora di
offrirlo come vi ho detto prima lo
presso amazon o poi vi lascio il link
così potete anche vedere il prezzo è in
pratica su scritto slang kit ma dentro
ci sono tantissime decorazioni ok
ragazze l'abbiamo fatto che andiamo un
po vediamo vediamo ora apriamo tutti
viviamo piccoli.le calzino calino le
nuovole un lemure l'arcobaleno il muro
anche allora possiamo vedere una cosa
per volta se non sintra finiamo quindi
questo modo le cose questo non è detto
che era finito chi è questo
poi passi sono pentito
e allora se ci sono delle palestine per
modellare di campo la sua cena poi
bambine bianche
queste sono grandi poi piccoline bianche
piccoline blu piccolino musicolor tuoi
grandi multicolor e piccoline
quindi abbiamo dovuto vedere sono
morbidi sul suo classico prodotto questi
momenti il ghetto e colorate non ho mai
trovato che gli online sono belle stesso
craxi guardate sono della scorta di
inchieste e ci sono dei tricolori 7 8 9
10 10 con noi
ecco le fa
fatemi sapere se mi avete mai usato
nello snai in quanto è figo questo sito
blake flakes infine una volta che le
autorità albertville e divisori tutti
guardate un po
questi sono tipo glitter un po più
grossi flakes mi mancava non aveva
ancora poi questi sono gli occhietti che
si muovono poi che non si piega be
allora questi sono i fogli dorati e
argento occhi quelli che si mettono sto
problemi non li amano del tutto sono
strumento però quindi mi servivano
perché io non ho mai fatto un en plein
con la pellicola dorata dettata sopra
che ci sono altri flakes ma da un
allegato il vostro in un'angusta
lastricato di romeno altri flakes gialli
che abbiamo delle faccine incollato già
tutto pietro guarda che cosa si parla
ossia la pellicola dedicata poi ma che
belli questi socio flixster acioli
allora sono i costi di frutta e quale
sterline piccoline
quali sono i fischi multicolor qualsiasi
dei questi sono altri flex gialli e faty
sono sulle lettere queste due bellissime
anche sono molto piccoli come sempre
slime allora questi sono tanti glitter
abbastanza grandi però dentro non sono
tantissimi vedrete che la boccetta e
piccola c'è una grande scelta di colori
però scrive troppo su tantissimi
assoluto rifiuto stelline l'ultimo
questo penso che sia per fare il
pressing slime fini godrà di un uomo
neanche mai fatto il pressing utlime non
scommessa con questo turno e non mollato
controllati ma poi li chiamano già
allora che cosa ne pensate mi faccio
schifo rimetto in link per vedere contro
calato penso che le quantità siamo molto
piccole non c è molta
certo molto sono molto carina non tutti
però sono molto vari e comunque sensato
di roma che non avrei mai pensato di
comprare tipo queste bugie ci sono le
piste colpo di remo quindi allora tutto
sommato sono contenta perché ho un bel
po di cose in più per fare lo slancio
forli ancora più fari
però insomma la con di tempo piccolina
poi quelli stufi potete vederle
carbonico magari potete trovarle ad un
prezzo migliore dai cinesi se avete
qualche negozi che fornito magari
trovando di meglio e ora andiamo a mente
aprire il laboratorio di fluidi cantori
mondo li chiamano fluidi schifosi disney
sono bellissimi ma rustici non sono
tifosi comprendiamo finalmente dà brio e
andiamo a provarlo
apriamo finalmente
[Applauso]
vediamo separate che se il foglietto di
istruzioni addirittura e quanti al
detenuto non in atto indagini sempre
allo stadio fronte potevano fare un poco
andrà fatto linee ma sono partire da
salim
[Applauso]
un summit ue di mike jones e lo stimo
tra l'altro quindi questo serve che di
un altro affare di flat senza colla
infatti non mi sembra di vedere con la
qua dentro
da ciò che c'è scritto tutto sto dentro
allineato di sodio altre porte
dell'attore che a castro priva di odore
e sapore anche queste sostanze di
origine vegetale in particolare deriva
dalle alghe da qui il nome allergy nato
come gli animali e un alto potere da
pensate unito ad altre sostanze tende a
formare influito gen a chi non mi sono
presa col questo colorante in polvere o
sopravvento lavoro di calcio di gomma di
guar questo anche questa senza feste bar
mentre abili una boccetta di calcio dal
punto di vista chimico quello di calcio
non sale proprio primo quello che si usa
come in cucina tanto è vero che anche
loro
lo stesso video non può due programmi
iglo scopi che attende la firma che
possiede inoltre l'elevata soli
mi sento un po il piccolo chimico come
quasi sono altre offerte non sono mai
sentite
quindi io non sapevo che questo kit in
realtà c'è scritto tutto nero della mia
libricino praticamente da prima una
visione generale su che cosa sono i
fluidi e schifoso seri sforzi che spiega
anche la differenza tra i vari fluidi
presenti sostanze rispose la bolla è
fuori un motore che secondo loro la
prima cosa che qui sopra il camino detto
casa ha comunque allora se come questo
video diventerebbe troppo lungo se ci
mettiamo a fare il drive senza collo che
stavo nostro con la quale ne avrei fatto
uno velocemente però sono senza colori
il processo sapete buche lungo quindi
magari se volete faccio un video in cui
faccio solo line senza colla su un posto
kit magari prova anche quelle maschere
durate argentata
fatemi sapere nei commenti se volete
vedere un video come faccio solo slam
senza collo con questo kit e con le
altre cose per un altro non c'è bisogno
di acquistare questo kit perché molti di
questi ingredienti io ce l'ho già
acquistati separatamente a meno che non
volete tutte queste ciotoline così non è
poi quando andiamo a testarli vediamo il
termale
però appena stato però il tricolore
perché l'avevo preso bendata quindi non
so proprio quanto costasse e quindi ma
adesso appare se volete vedere un video
dedicato in cui facciamo i dialetti sono
i piccoli chimici ea quella cosa li
costringerà per gli occhialetti dove
visto dislocato a gesù non è che qualche
solone tesoro per chiudere ha speso
selettivo un perfetto chimico quindi di
tripoli se volete vedere altri non slime
cose slime shopping virtuali scrive tesi
tutto nei commenti lasciati bellanca
questo video e raggiunge 10.000 la ex
andremo a fare un altro gol e shopping
con noi e ora vi lasciamo al 34
caselline su cui potete cliccare per
vedere i prossimi video i nostri video
divertenti video klein cliccare su
quella che preferite e buona visione so
se mi sterili